هل تكرهين
الاستيقاظ في الصباح، وكذلك دوريس،
جميع الأبقار في مزرعة ريد بجزيرة
وايت في إنجلترا، استيقظت وغادرت
للحلب باستثناء دوريس،
تتظاهر دوريس بالفعل بالنوم
وتتظاهر بالنوم، وقد
انتشرت دوريس على نطاق واسع.  أنا دوريس كان
تعليقًا نموذجيًا أوه، أليس كذلك،
تتمتع دوريس بشخصية رائعة، إنها
بالتأكيد شخص أكثر من بقرة، إنها
واحدة من المفضلات لدى جون برودي، أنت
صانع الأذى، اترك قهوتي بمفردها
من فضلك عندما تظاهرت دوريس بأنها نائمة
جون  ناديتها دوريس هيا، أراك
تتحرك، هيا أستطيع أن أرى
عينك، نعم، أعرف أنها كانت تتظاهر
بحوالي 30 ثانية قبل أن
ترفع رأسها وكانت تنظر إلي مباشرة، ثم
أعادت رأسها إلى الأسفل معتقدة
أنها ستفعل ذلك  ابتعد عن الأمر فقط
لدفعها إلى الأعلى وكن صفيقًا الآن لدى دوريس
معجبين عبر الإنترنت أعتقد أنني وجدت
حيواني الروحي يترك دوريس بمفردها لكن دوريس
لا تترك جون بمفرده ولماذا كانت
تلعق الجزء الخلفي من رأسك
أم تعتني بي  تعني،
بقدر ما يهمني، أنها
تقبلني كعضو في القطيع، وتقوم
برعاية فأرها
الجني CNN New York